[Music]
an all-wheel drive crossover in Ireland
ideal terrain for the new Suzuki sx4 s
cross to show what it's capable of the
weather here seems to change by the hour
from wind and rain to blue skies our car
reviewer Michelle wants to see whether
the SX 4s cross lives up to Suzuki's
promise to get you where you're going
fast rain or shine
she's testing the version with a 1.4
liter gasoline engine delivering 103
kilowatts of power and a peak torque of
220 Newton meters
it makes the dash to 100 kilometers per
hour and a little over 10 seconds the
manufacturers fuel economy rating is 5.6
liters for 100 kilometers our Edition
has the comfort plus equipment line
prices in Germany started just under 29
thousand euros personally Michelle finds
the engine a little weak and the
steering too soft
she misses that feedback from the
driving surface
among the optional extras is the
all-wheel-drive system all grip last
year's facelift added two new engines to
choose from there's the 1 liter
3-cylinder diesel unit with 82 kilowatts
and the newest and most powerful
gasoline Edition that we're testing
the sx/4 s-cross does not have permanent
all-wheel drive it's primarily powered
via the front axle if it loses traction
the car switches to both axles this can
take a little more time than expected a
feeling that takes getting used to
[Music]
but now it's time to unleash all grip as
we go off-road our forest course
provides its fair share of obstacles the
gravel tracked us and seemed to really
challenge the sx4 s cross but what about
more slippery conditions the crossover
certainly has the right color for this
adventure at least
even deep potholes and seriously muddy
sections are unable to unsettle this car
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the front gives the sx/4 s-cross a broad
and chunky appearance measuring 4.3
meters long there's plenty of space for
rear passengers thanks to a ground
clearance of 180 millimeters it can
master regular and bumpy roads with ease
and take on off-road passages pretty
safely even when things get a bit rocky
[Music]
Suzuki has definitely fulfilled its
promises Michelle its off-road abilities
mean the SX 4s cross gets you where you
want to go fast on the road or
cross-country
you